N goo
Yakuza I love baths I
love fighting I also love I can
only enter the 15 minutes you see in the prison
I'm Tatsuya Shindo I'm currently using the north, but
I've been a yakuza for the past 25
years  I've been in prison three times, and now
I'm supporting people who have come out of prison
.
Today, I watch TV and movies
and evaluate how low the yakuza in the video is.
Masu yeah yeah yeah
Naono Tanaka It
looks like the end of the thing in my heart There
are many women like yakuza already,
but I have never seen anyone on that list of yakuza memberships
here today  It's a mistake to get up in the
yakuza, Mr. Naoto Ishii,
and love is okay with a bell fire. You
don't have to be a Japanese to become a reverse mountain.
It doesn't matter if there are five people in the center or how many people there are because there is a background that people who are
oppressed and are thrown out in Japanese society the next morning
have lived in the world of yakuza
.
The biggest
mistake in this movie is
that I'm having this meeting at the executive committee. It's unlikely that I'll
kill you, and
of course there's a gangster in my gangster.
There is a
gangster case, but this is not the case here.
B 2 About
the culture
of gangsters Yubitsume is to look
at me a
gangster I don't have a gangster I'm also a
gangster  So I'm a general,
so for example, when I can't
repay the debt, I repay the debt with my finger,
or I'm sorry, I stuff my finger when I apologize
.
It
's not
here with the palm
up. From here I'm going from the capital joint.
From
here I
'm not doing
this well.  What comes to me when I do
it Tomorrow
's snapping and yakuza
Yubitsume is only burnt now.
This brt is 8
Why do we do something like this Basic
Hannan
Okay Ah, that actor named Hiroyuki Sanada in this movie
is quite
brewing.
The atmosphere is the atmosphere of a yakuza. If a
yakuza looks suspicious and weak,
you can't eat that food, so it's a
creature that you have to be strong
.
Then, it's good to
create it, right? Create an atmosphere as a
whole.
[Music]
Well
, some of the people in my ward group are actually
killing people with that kind of sword.
But
there is no such thing as slashing between swords. There is almost no swords
.
The reality of this video
is
zero
. You went there a long time ago.
It
’s not good on the
gangster, but I ’m closing my eyes.
Basically, it ’s not allowed for the drug to use a
gangster.
Drowning
and the law and regulation apartment where you can't yakuza at the student stand. If
you don't have him, you can't make a bank account
.
It's
not done
now. Nowadays, the yakuza is
over. It's the time when the country is seriously
trying to get rid of
the grass and
win 5 books
. This yakuza will finally
live as a human being.
The yakuza can't make a loan anymore because all the techniques have been taken. I
can't make a
loan
.
It's not said that such a young person will become a yakuza,
right? I'll finish this. I
can't eat a gangster if it's clean. It's
very difficult for a yakuza
to stop a yakuza.
That's why I enter, unless there is something wrong with me  It's a
world where I can't say
I'm
quitting from
I've become a Christian.
I lived in a church and
got help.
And now I'm here. Don't
say I'm worried.
[Music]
Yakuza, I love bathing, I love
fighting dice.
Would you like to wear a gangster that
you can't even see when you go to the bath?
Saying Harger Juet Nanase
Well, it's decided. If you have a
blade length longer than this, the
handle will be arrested soon,
so you can't take it unnecessarily.
This isn't messed up anymore.  There is a
10-point
rating on the rear of
this area.
It
's a tentative thing that must be returned. It's difficult even if
that category of in-law is
amazing. It's a world of
wood
culture.  Var Good
Wither
Spoonche Inverted gangsters return the gangsters It depends on what you are not afraid of and how long you can
Graph
There may be international activities for smuggling such things,
but
there
are three things that can be said to be active internationally when you go abroad
.
This now-painted t is
Arita It's dangerous to say no now-
Japanese people have been around for a long time This movie
itself is already a
bigrally of wars
3rd World Battle
50 years from 1945  From
this era to the present,
the mainstream
drugs of the Japanese engine are stimulants. This movie is basically a
real yakuza
kiss, right
? I became a yakuza when I was a kid.  So I regret that I
should have had a yakuza if I hadn't done
it.
Of course, I
wouldn't go for fun, I wouldn't
divorce my wife, and my
child wouldn't be
unhappy.
Everything is
affirmed by meeting God by meeting Kiris.
[Applause] The
most common internal conflict among
yakuza is
that of the post-mare.  That's why
it's important to secure a needle, isn't it?
Considering the background of the times,
this
reality is that the
gangsters were made to
do the gangsters and the prisoners who made good profits of the yakuza.
I don't think
this movie is a
real yakuza
movie called Rikio Ishikawa
, so this person really commits himself in Fuchu
Prison. Jumping down and inside the yakuza  That's
right, it's
about 1/3. It's
just a social need for a management contradiction.
It means that the
criminal is
right, so I'm working for that composition.
I made a promise at that show.
There is no love day in the gangster trip now, and there
is a line of people like
this. I really want to improve Japan through this.
Because
I was helped, the reality is me.
The admission for the tattoo was canceled.
9 people. It feels like a
gangster.
If
you do, you can't use the gangster,
which narrows the scope of this activity. And in Japan
, the
image of a gangster
is that the gangster is a criminal.
I
couldn't say that I put a tattoo here because there is this public department.
3 = The criminal
is a Japanese dna.  You have a tattoo in your head
, right? I'll show you a
lot of tattoos, not just medicine
.
7th question
I've seen a lot of carvings, but this is the
first cherry blossom I saw.
Let's emblem the group's Daimon and the emblem.
The
gangster who is the chest or the older brother is
n't here till now, but I have to
show it like
this.  There are many things, but
I never want to show it. I have a god called a wind god and a
thunder god.
My name is Tatsuya dragon, so a little dragon is
included. I actually
have the name of the boss boss here.  But if you
look at it here, you know what this person is calling,
the reality of the movie is
2. Show me the game and say that
I'm not in the leaf pool with a high bath.
It's embarrassing to say that there are no people who are confused at this time, isn't
it?
I don't say that even though I'm called by the police without guidance and I don't say
that.
It doesn't happen all the
time. It
may have been a long time ago that we had a meeting, but it's not so terrible and
it's
safe, so if the attack mass is unilaterally
sloppy, we attack 2 cases.
Yakuza don't even target the general public It
's a problem every day that there aren't many scenes dealing with tattoos. Is
the yakuza using tattoos only in conflict cases
?
The reality of this scene was actually